In today's video,
we are trying out 4 new methods
to stress test batteries,
push them to their limits, and
see what will happen to them.
[Music]
You may recall a previous video
where we took
a bunch of batteries,
and we tested them,
damaging them in ways that
you're really not supposed to.
We drove nails through them,
we cut them in half, smash them,
and we just hit them
with a blow torch.
That was really fun.
I like seeing what happened,
but we can take
it a step further.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got a bunch of alkaline
and lithium batteries.
We're going to see what
happens if we deep fry them,
weld them, freeze them,
and chop them with an ax.
We've got a bunch
of our alkaline batteries.
We've got some
of our lithium batteries,
and we've got four new tests,
four new ways to
destroy batteries,
things that you are definitely
not supposed to do,
and we're going to try it.
[Music]
Alright, so we've got
our voltmeter here.
Before we put our batteries
into the liquid nitrogen,
we are going to see what sort
of output reading we get
from the batteries.
This Energizer Ultimate
lithium battery is giving us
1.806 volts of DC,
and our Duracell alkaline battery
is giving us 1.613 volts DC.
All right, starting
with the Duracell.
Here it goes.
[Music]
That's only been in
for a couple seconds,
but just to see
if there's any change, I'm just
gonna give it another test.
This was 1.613, I think.
Now, it's given us 1.5,
but it's climbing.
As the battery-- Okay.
1.553 is what we're getting now.
So that's down a little bit.
Let's throw it back in,
and let's just let
it go until it--
Until it stops bubbling,
and then a couple more minutes
after that to really get it cold.
Our Duracell alkaline battery
has now been our liquid nitrogen
for about five minutes,
and the liquid nitrogen has
mostly stop bubbling around it.
There's still some
bubbles coming off,
it's just not as violent
as it was before.
But I think we're ready
to test it again.
So we are at 38 millivolts.
So that's like 0.03, I think.
That is very very little power.
This is how we find out just
how good my hammer aim is.
[Music]
What have I done?
I think it split open.
It did.
Freeze your hand pretty quick.
Yeah, it's very cold.
But look at that!
[Music]
You can use
a little more finesse,
and a little less power.
[Music]
That's awesome.
That is, I'd say
the entire contents
of an alkaline battery.
Now, if you remember
from our last video,
all of this right here,
this was paste.
This black stuff here.
[Music]
All right.
Let's test the voltage
on this bad boy.
We are at an
astonishing 301 mil--
It's bottoming out basically.
It's--
>> Oh, now it's up to 30 millivolts.
>> Negative.
No, no.
There was a negative
there for a second.
This is just jumping
all over the place.
It can't handle this.
Oh, now we're up to 1.7 volts.
It like got its voltage back.
That was quick.
I don't think the alkaline
battery did that.
Nope.
Not the same.
Probably because it
has this paste
that was no longer paste,
and not doing its thing.
All right.
[Music]
Hmm.
Oh, I also broke one.
Oh, I can smell that though.
Yep.
Oh.
[Music]
Interesting.
So this one, I am curious about.
I kind of suspect as it warms
up, it might just ignite,
because we've now
probably made the layers
of the inside metal touch.
But I don't know
how warm it will have to get
before it does that.
Okay, we've got
our two batteries.
I'm a little nervous about what
the lithium one's going to do,
because these do have
a tendency to light on fire
if they get too hot.
I don't know if oil
will get it there,
but it like might
make it expand,
and then the metal
inside could touch,
and then that could
make it light.
Batteries into the deep fryer.
One alkaline.
One lithium.
If we conclude
that it's finished doing
whatever it's going to do,
then we're just going
to unplug the machine,
wait for a few minutes,
and then try
and carefully come out,
and lift things off.
We'll see what we can do.
Oh, I think the wrapper
around the Duracell
battery has come off.
I can't actually see
the Energizer battery.
I really really thought
it was gonna have a more
explosive reaction this.
Oh, wait, spoke too soon.
Looks like the alkaline battery
just started sort
of spurting out the negative.
Yes.
Something pop.
I think the alkaline battery
was doing something,
and then the Energizer lithium
battery also did something
at the same time.
No, nope.
Here goes the alkaline.
The alkaline has now
started freaking out.
Now, okay.
So instead of popping
like the lithium did,
this one just fizzled out.
That lithium one,
it just sort of popped,
and it launched itself up
out of the fryer, splashing
oil all over our canvas tarp,
and then it landed
a few feet away.
The alkaline one still seems
to be bubbling rather furiously.
Fizzling, fizzling, popping.
I don't think we can use
this fry oil for anything else.
So this is warm to the touch.
We're going to leave it alone
for a minute here,
because you can see
that it obviously expanded.
But I can't see
where that leak was
that made it just freaked out,
and explode out
of the deep fryer.
When we've heated up
the lithium batteries before,
there's sort of a top
cap attached to it,
and that has popped off.
This one, I mean
the top cap is still there,
but it may have loosened.
So one leaked slowly
for a long time,
and one leaked to very quickly
for a short amount of time.
[Music]
Well, it really looks pretty.
Oh, it overheated.
[Music]
Probably a good
burning acid smell.
So our battery here
overheated very quickly,
started leaking.
We got spot.
It looks like it
leaked at the side,
or maybe I managed to weld
a little bit there.
We kind of lost our connection.
The battery of course
has to have a connection for it
to actually weld anything.
The electricity has
to flow through...
So I can weld on anything
that this is connected to.
But our battery, while it did
get somewhere at first...
I don't know.
I want to try that again,
but I'm gonna peel
the coating off
so the whole battery is metal,
and I don't have the plastic
getting in the way.
This one, I think has potential
to be even more exciting.
Because that one
kept moving so much.
I'm gonna try and get
this be held even more
sturdily by our magnet.
[Music]
Oh, that's awesome.
It's lit.
And it will probably light
even more violently still.
Beautiful.
Very nice bright pink color.
Can you see the glow?
Oh, yeah.
Wow.
So this time,
I've scraped off some of the
outside coating on the battery,
and I'm going to see
what happens if I weld straight
into the side of it.
Whoa.
[Music]
All right.
I'm going to back up.
I want to be clear
that I'm not backing up
because I'm worried
about the battery.
I'm backing up
because Nate is a terrible shot
when it comes to using an axe.
Hey.
[Music]
Well, you hit it.
I did.
Oh, that looks awesome.
It's actually a decent hit.
Yeah.
It wasn't a perfect hit,
but it was a decent hit.
[Music]
Oh my god!
Yeah.
I take it back.
>> I take back everything I said.
>> Severed!
Severed that battery.
It's a perfect hit.
All right.
Other than being chopped
in half though,
it hasn't really done anything.
Let's see if the lithium ones
are more exciting.
Just hit it.
[Music]
What?
You did it, first try.
[Music]
I kinda thought that would--
Oh, it's fizzing.
Okay.
Well, maybe don't be holding it.
Let it sit there
in case it fizzes
into something more exciting.
[Music]
Wow.
You got it.
We only have one left.
Go for it.
I am probably not a good
enough shot for this one.
[Music]
You smooshed it,
and I didn't actually chop it,
it just smooshed it.
Hit the side.
It wasn't a bull's
eye right on the side.
I was off by quarter
of a millimeter this time,
and the blade just like
smooshed it sideways.
[Music]
Battery Destruction Part
2, a success.
Guys, that's it for today,
but we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And this bomb here
in the middle, you hit that,
you'll be subscribed,
and you never miss
out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.